hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcasts prostate cancer screening
update 2016 I am Christina mahalik of
lab roots and he'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by labyrinth we have a field
for announcements before we begin this
broadcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the events you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button on the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
here in this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the grain Q&A
button located in your lower left corner
this is an educational women webinar in
the offers free continuing education
credits the webinar with after the
webinar just over runner please click on
the cee button located at the bottom
left hand corner of your web page and
follow the process of obtaining your
credits i will now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. jed now dr. Jeff
Maehl is james h siemens indeed
professor of surgery division of
urologic surgery and director of the
Duke prostate Center do Cancer Institute
at Drake University Medical Center in
2004 he completed a 26 year US Army
career retiring as a full colonel in the
Medical Corps it became chief of the
division of urologic surgery at duke
stirring as chief from 2004 to 2011 he
started the dude prostate Center
it is now a full-time member of the Duke
Cancer Institute and sees many men with
elevated PSA in all stages of prostate
cancer doctor Mao is widely published in
the field and is a noted international
authority on prostate cancer screening
and treatment I will now turn it over to
dr. Mao for his presentation thank you
doctor you very much it's not really a
pleasure and honor to be here I'm going
to today talk about prostate cancer
screening and we're going to provide an
update for 2016 as many of you listening
in today are probably aware of prostate
screening has gotten to be extremely
controversial over the last couple years
and we'll go into some of this
controversy and then hopefully have some
time for Question and Answer about some
of the common scenarios you may face in
your practice when you're mad at having
a patient in front of you who has an
elevated PSA or is trying to decide if
they would like to be screened for
prostate cancer when we talk about
screening for any disease whether it be
prostate cancer breast cancer or even a
non-malignant condition the goals of any
screening program are listed on this
slide the disease should be a
life-threatening disease you should use
an accurate screening test the test
should have high sensitivity sensitivity
meaning that the test is positive if the
patient actually has the disease the
test should also have high specificity
meaning that if the patient does not
have the disease the test should be
negative the costs of the detection of
the disease must be acceptable there
should be effective treatment available
for the disease in other words why
screen for something if you cannot treat
it
the treatment must have acceptable
morbidity in other words that you know
the treatment must be acceptable to
patients you're not causing more harm
than good and then most importantly the
program this entire program should
improve survival and to have an ideal
screening test for any disease or
condition they should meet all these
criteria so what's been going on well in
2012 and then it was published in 2013
the US Preventive Services Task Force
and you see on this slide that's
abbreviated as USPSTF basically the task
force found that PSA testing did not
really result in a benefit and so they
came to the conclusion that PSA testing
was essentially no good and recommitted
de-rating which basically means that
they felt that there was more harm than
good in the PSA test now how in the
world did they come to that the PSA test
had been used since the late 1980s or
early 1990s and was a has been a
widespread screening test for prostate
cancer and then all of a sudden in 2012
2013 this guideline group that's part of
the or at least authorized by the
federal government came out saying the
PSA test should not be used well before
we talk about the pros and cons what has
happened since 2012 is that we've seen
primary care physicians you know take
the US Preventive Services Task Force to
heart and they have basically stopped
screening for prostate cancer and as a
result of that what we're starting to
see now is rates of more advanced
prostate cancer go up in other words
when you stop screening for
condition the condition itself doesn't
go away but the stage at diagnosis goes
up you're catching the cancer later and
we're starting to see evidence of that
in light of the backlash against
screening and not using the PSA test but
other experts say we've thrown the baby
out with the bathwater meaning you know
we've stopped screening for prostate
cancer using the PSA test and was that a
hasty decision was that decision made
rationally was that decision made on the
best evidence and now looking back after
a couple of years there are many experts
who believe that we did throw the baby
out with the bathwater and that the US
Preventive Services Task Force may have
overreacted in giving the PSA test of D
rating let's look at some of the
prostate cancer screening trials and
have been conducted and there's evidence
going back as early as 2004 from a study
from Scandinavia then there was a Quebec
study from Canada in 2004 and another
small study from Stockholm in 2009 that
provided some evidence but not really
good evidence on the benefits or harms
of screening but highlighted on this
slide are the plc o trial and the
european randomized study for prostate
cancer screening both of these key
studies randomised trial were published
in 2009 in the New England Journal of
Medicine and both of these trials form
the basis for why the US Preventive
Services Task Force gave the PSA test of
D rating so those two studies in 2009
those two randomized trials were what
drove the guidelines from the US
Preventive Services Task Force so let's
take a look at these two major clinical
trials of prostate cancers
reading and the trials gave conflicting
results first the US / the US study was
which was called the again PLC oh the
conclusions published a new england
journal of medicine were that after
seven to ten years of follow-up the rate
of deaths from prostate cancer was very
low and did not differ significantly
between the two study groups to study
groups were the group that was
randomized to be getting the PSA test
and a group that was randomized to
routine care which mean they did not
have the PSA test as part of this
defined clinical trial now the other
study the European study which you see
down the second part of this slide
showed PSA based screening reduce the
rate of death from prostate cancer by
twenty percent but was associated with a
high risk of overdiagnosis so in other
words we have one clinical trial saying
that PSA testing did not result in a
declining death rate from prostate
cancer that was the American study and
but yet the European study said that
screening reduced the death rate from
prostate cancer by twenty percent but
they talk about overdiagnosis in other
words there were a lot of men that they
diagnosed with very early stage prostate
cancer and many of these were elderly
men and they said in effect that you
know they opened up a can of worms in a
certain group of older men and picked up
cancers that should have never been
detected so they did find a benefit but
they also found some over detection now
these trials were designed differently
first off the American trial the PLC o
trial was conducted in the United States
the European trial was conducted in
Europe and the PLC o trial found no
mortality benefit in favour of PSA
testing the European study found a
twenty percent mortality in favour of
PSA testing
the plc oh trial enrolled 76,000 men the
European trial enrolled 182,000 men the
PLC Oh plc Oh used a PSA threshold of
4.0 and the European trial used a PSA
threshold of 3.0 in other words what
does this mean what is a PSA threshold
mean that man in the clinical trial if a
participant had a PSA level above 4 or
above three that would have been the
trigger to make the referral to
urologist who would have been
recommended a prostate biopsy now fifty
percent of the subjects in the American
trial actually received a biopsy in
other words only fifty percent of the
patients who had a PSA threshold above
for actually received a prostate biopsy
on the other hand the European trial
eighty-five percent of men who had an
abnormal PSA or biopsy so that's a big
difference and then the biggest problem
with the American trom the biggest
problem with the plc Oh trial if you
don't really remember anything else
about this talk today the key teaching
point is that fifty-two percent or more
than half of the men enrolled in the
control group actually had a PSA test
and you say well how can that be these
were men who were randomized to no
screening well PSA was already common in
the United States at that time and so
more than half of the man who were
enrolled in this trial in the control
group got a PSA on the sly with their
primary care physician and so in the
European trial at the time this study
was done there was very little PSA
testing done in Europe so there was less
opportunity for patients to get a sneaky
PS
done outside the confines of the trial
and so the PSA contamination rate was
only twenty percent and so that's that's
really the two clinical trials that
resulted in this D rating from the US
Preventive Services Task Force ah the
major criticism of the plc of the major
criticism this was the American trial
was that PSA was tested frequently in
the control group as I said earlier
there was a high contamination rate
forty percent of the men who were
randomized to the control group where
they were not supposed to get PSA
testing forty percent outside the trial
went to another doctor and had a PSA
test during that first year fifty-two
percent by year six and so one can
understand how contaminated the control
group is if you're trying to test
whether PSA testing makes a difference
you would have needed a control group
that would have had much less PSA
testing and so that many people feel
that the plc o trial is so flawed that
it should not have even been used in the
deliberations of the US Preventive
Services Task Force but in summary these
five screening trials and when we talked
earlier briefly about the trial and
Scandinavia the Quebec trial the
Stockholm trial these were smaller
studies and two of the three earlier
studies did not show a major benefit to
screening but the Quebec trial did show
reduced mortality in the group of men
who were assigned to PSA testing then
the two major trials plc o showed no
benefit but hype esa contaminate
contamination rate and the european
trial showed a twenty percent
improvement in prostate cancer mortality
and men who were screened but also there
were some differences country to country
and how the study was actually conducted
so this is a summary of the screening
trial
then Cochran did a systematic review of
the screening studies and that was done
in 2013 and what did we learn from the
Cochrane systematic review well
screening was associate with an
increased diagnosis of prostate cancer
again if you introduce any screening
test to a population in this case PSA
the men who got the PSA test how to
higher rate of cancer detection and the
men who were randomized to no testing
that makes sense also screening was
associated with more localized disease
meaning if you screened for prostate
cancer you found more cases of disease
that was confined to the prostate and
less advanced prostate cancer but
according to Cochrane pull data from all
five of the randomized trials 341
thousand participants showed no
reduction in cancer-specific mortality
now again you could argue that garbage
in garbage out because the cochrane
review did include the plc Oh American
trial and since the American trial had
such tremendous contamination in the
control group one could have argued that
it was inappropriate for Cochran to
include this trial in the systemic
review but nevertheless it was included
and as a result this systematic review
suggests no survival benefit to PSA
testing again no reduction in all-cause
or prostate cancer-specific mortality
but as we said there are criticisms of
this systematic review that the risk of
biases was signing study under
consideration however they did not
account for the differing rates of PSA
contamination and again as I said
earlier more than half of the patients
in the PLC o did have PSA contamination
more than half of those men in the
control group who were randomized to
know PSA testing had gotten a PSA 10
outside the confines of the trial and
then differing rates of biopsy for
screen positive subjects so this is
where we are or where we were if we look
at the most recent update of the
European randomized study for prostate
cancer screening there is now reported
at twenty-seven percent reduction in
prostate cancer-specific mortality at
thirteen year follow-up for the men who
did get a PSA test so in long-term
follow-up this large European trial
shows a significant benefit in favour of
PSA testing compared to men who were not
screened and that's illustrated on the
left side of this PowerPoint slide now
another study that was not included in
the studies that the US Preventive
Services Task Force is called the go to
berg study this is a study from
Scandinavia where younger man between 55
and 69 were randomized to screening
versus no screen we haven't talked about
the go to berg study until now in the
talk and this particular latest study
again was not included in the US
Preventive Services Task Force
deliberations in 2012 and 2013 but this
can inform us quite a bit because these
were younger patients and the follow up
on this trial was reported out at 14
years of follow-up so with long
follow-up and screening a younger group
of men with PSA they found a forty-four
percent reduction in prostate
cancer-specific mortality at 14 years of
follow-up so not only do we have the
European randomized study for prostate
cancer screening showing a twenty-seven
percent reduction in deaths from
prostate cancer
men who were screened at thirteen years
but the goethe burg study shows a
forty-four percent reduction at 14 years
and the N and B that you see on this
slide that means number needed to
diagnose with prostate cancer to save
one life in the European study you need
to needed to diagnose 27 prostate
cancers in 27 men in order to prevent
one prostate cancer death at 13 years of
follow-up in the Goldberg trial number
needed to diagnose was 12 in other words
you needed to diagnose 12 men with
prostate cancer to alleviate one death
from prostate cancer 14 years later and
those numbers are very comparable to
what we see in other diseases where
screening is accepted those numbers are
very similar to for example men mog
raphy screening for breast cancer or
colonoscopy for colorectal cancer so the
key teaching point is that there are two
randomized trials that show a benefit to
PSA testing and the benefit is
comparable to screening efforts in other
diseases where we accept that screening
test is useful now what are the harms
associated with prostate cancer
screening well you certainly have some
harm associated with prostate biopsy
there's some pain associate with a
biopsy of the prostate there's some risk
of blood and the semen some risk of
hematuria some risk of blood in the
bowel movements for a period of time
after the biopsy and some small risk of
infection requiring hospitalization
after a prostate biopsy but the biggest
risk specifically related to prostate
cancer is over diagnosis and many people
believe that the US Preventive Services
task force was gave the PSA tested
derating not so much on the PSA test
itself but the downstream consequences
of screening in other words the task
force was not able to necessarily
differentiate or separate the PSA test
itself from the downstream results and
they said basically that hey prostate
cancer screening is not that valuable
all you're going to do is over diagnose
a bunch of small unimportant prostate
cancers and elderly man and open up a
Pandora's box by over diagnosing all
these men and and that's the main beef
that people have had with prostate
cancer screening what was not taken into
account in 2012 and 2013 when the US
Preventive Services Task Force met was
the use of active surveillance and
what's happened between 2012 and now is
that we are we are combating this over
diagnosis by recognizing but a lot of
these young older men with low volume
prostate cancer can be placed on active
surveillance so we're not treating all
these men at this point overdiagnosis is
still a possibility but over we're
trying to combat that with not being
aggressively treating many of these men
with low stage prostate cancer
especially if they're older so with
improved risk stratification
overdiagnosis does not necessarily lead
to over treatment as I mentioned over
the last four years clinicians who take
care of men with prostate cancer are
much more likely to do proper risk
assessment of those men who are
diagnosed and much more commonly
applying active surveillance or close
monitoring we're not necessarily
treating all of these men with surgery
or radiotherapy we're treating a lot of
these men with
close a watch and wait scenario so that
we're trying to combat the overdiagnosis
and not over treat many of these men
what I want to do in the next group of
slides is talk a little bit about
guidelines and I'm a urologist and a
member of the American Urological a shin
so I'd like to spend a few slides
talking about the American Urological
prostate cancer guidelines now these are
not the end-all guidelines these are
there as I'll show in a few minutes
there are quite a few organizations that
have prostate cancer guidelines and
we'll compare and contrast those later
but right now let's spend the next
couple of slides what is the American
urologic Association say about PSA
testing well the urology Association
guidelines broke it down into four age
groups men less than 40 then aged 40 to
50 for men aged 55 to 69 and Men 70
years of age or older because prostate
cancer is such a slow generally a slow
growing cancer and since we're trying to
comp at overdiagnosis and overtreatment
in elderly men we thought it made sense
to try to stratify or think about men in
these for age groups within reference to
how we would screen them for prostate
cancer so first off if you have a
patient in your practice who is less
than 40 years of age even if that
gentleman does have a family history for
example of prostate cancer the
guidelines generally recommend against
PSA based screening for men under age 40
reason being is that there's such a low
incidence and prevalence of prostate
cancer in very young men that it really
just does not make sense to recommend
PSA testing in men in your practice who
are less than age 40 and I think that's
fairly clear
in the forty to fifty four year age
group screaming as a routine is not
recommended in men between ages 40 and
50 for who are at average risk of
prostate cancer now what does average
risk me well let's look at it a
different way what does high-risk mean
so we know that african-american men men
who self described as black or
african-american men and men who report
a family history of prostate cancer are
at higher risk what this is saying that
if a man is not african-american and if
a man does not have a family history of
prostate cancer he would be at average
risk and perhaps we wouldn't
automatically offer him periodic PSA
screening between ages 40 and 50 for now
I'm going to talk a little bit later
about using a baseline PSA to better
assess the risk of these men between 40
and 50 for but will hold that thought
for now and that about baseline PSA but
in general the aua guidelines do not
generally recommend routine periodic you
nearly or every other year PSA testing
for men 40 to 50 for the reason being is
the randomized trials that we discussed
earlier did not include men under age 55
in those randomized trials so there's no
level one evidence from the clinical
trials that I've already talked about
about men 4254 there's just no
randomized data to know if screening is
beneficial we know the probability of
dying from prostate cancer by or before
age 55 is extremely low by seer data we
know that there's an extremely low a
number of deaths
could be prevented in screening men in
this young age group and so again in
general for an average risk man at age
40 to 50 for the guide the aua
guidelines do not call for routine PSA
screening now the group where there's
the strongest evidence for testing is in
the age group 55 to 69 and the panel a
you a panel recommends a shared
decision-making for men aged 55 269
considering PSA testing and proceeding
based on the patient's values and
preferences in plain English they say
that we should explain the pros and cons
but in general if you're going to do PSA
testing this age group between 55 and 69
makes the most sense of testing you're
going to have the largest benefit for
screening in this group in all
likelihood and this is the group of men
aged 55 and 69 that were studied in the
ghota berg clinical trial I'd referred
to earlier where there's the strongest
benefit in favor of screening so this is
where the aua really thinks we should
put our efforts again shared decision we
should still explain the pros and cons
of PSA testing even for men in this age
group and so in other words you
shouldn't just automatically do the PSA
test you know just the meeting ordering
this blood test without explaining the
pros and cons but once you'd explain the
pros and cons in the patient wants to
move forward with testing this is the
age group 4055 269 where it makes most
sense and the screening interval in this
group of men is every two years in other
words the aua guidelines would say that
the group where the strongest date is
for screening is men in your
practice in age 55 you get a PSA at 55
and then you would test them every two
years through 869 and intervene or do a
biopsy if they have an abnormal PSA
during that interval but at least as far
as which group to focus on it was 55 to
69 and doing testing every two years now
let's move on to the last group of
patients and that's men in your practice
who are age 70 and above and the AUA
guidelines recommended recommends
against routine PSA screening in men
aged 70 plus or in any patient with less
than a 10 to 15 year life expectancy
reason being that prostate cancer is
generally a slow growing cancer and
therefore you really do not want to open
up a Pandora's box on screening an older
man where they're not likely to live
long enough to see a benefit for
diagnosis and treatment of that prostate
cancer now on the other hand we've to
individualize there's some men over age
70 who are in excellent health who may
in fact benefit from prostate cancer
screening and again that's up to with us
as clinicians to make that individual
judgment but in general many men above
70 who especially the ones who are not
enjoying excellent help who have other
health conditions certainly things that
might take their life in the next 10 to
15 years we really don't have any
business ordering a PSA test than those
men because they're not likely to
benefit again beyond age 70 there's
really no evidence for screening benefit
from the European trial and certainly
overdiagnosis increases with age so I
think the worst thing we could do is you
know take an elderly man in his mid-70s
who has a bunch of other health
conditions diagnose a low-grade prostate
cancer
and then it that sets in motion a series
of events where he might end up getting
over treated for that low-grade low
stage prostate cancer now let's say you
do have a man in your practice who is
above 70 who does get a PSA test the aua
guidelines also say that maybe we can be
a little more liberal on what PSA
thresholds we would use to recommend a
prostate biopsy and this example here
they say that perhaps in many men in
their 70s you could probably monitor
that patient until the PSA for example
blows goes as high as 10 before you
would consider a prostate biopsy
especially in the setting of an older
man who has bph has an enlarged prostate
gland where much of that PSA is elevated
not due to prostate cancer but just due
to the prostate enlargement there's been
quite a bit of data out there also on
looking at PSA levels in men in their
early 70s and several studies have said
look if you have a guy at age 70 who has
a PSA that's let three or less or 3.5 or
less that given his life expectancy if
he gets to 70 and as a PSA of three or
three and a half his chances of
developing life-threatening prostate
cancer are exceedingly low so in other
words using that baseline or that
threshold of three in a 70 year old man
to say to reassure him say look your PSA
is only 3 or 70 years old the chance of
you developing clinically relevant
prostate cancer during your natural life
span or so low let's stop testing let's
just monitor you for other conditions
that where we can make a difference but
let's put prostate screening off the
table now at age 70 because your PSA is
low now I mentioned earlier I was going
to show a slide of the various
organizations screening guidelines in
yellow on this slide you see the US
Preventive
this task force that we talked about at
the top of the hour for this program and
remember the US Preventive Services Task
Force does not recommend PSA testing and
anybody so you see that came out in 2012
they don't recommend a baseline PSA they
don't recommend PSA in any group at any
age under any conditions the other
organizations have taken various stances
I talked about the aua guidelines in
detail and the different age groups the
AUA primarily recommends PSA testing
between 55 and 69 on an every to year
basis I'm not going to go through all of
these other guidelines but I did put a
red box around baseline PS and i said
earlier that i was going to come back to
that what does baseline PSA means mean
that means that for example let's say
you have a gentleman in your practice at
age 40 or 45 at that age you are going
to do a PSA test some people would call
that screening but the other reason
you're doing that test is to get a
baseline PSA value the reason that is
important is multiple studies have shown
now that the baseline PSA at that
younger man's age at 40 or 45 is a very
strong predictor of future prostate
cancer in fact baseline PSA Trump's age
family history and ethnicity as risk
factors for prostate cancer in other
words I said earlier african-american
ethnicity or family history that those
are risk factors for prostate cancer and
that's true but a man at 40 who has a
baseline PSA level of greater than 1.5
that 1.5 PSA at 40 is a stronger risk
factor for the future development of
prostate cancer
than his family history or his ethnicity
so that's why you see on the slide the
Europeans the National Comprehensive
Cancer Network and others have
recommended that physicians consider
getting a baseline PSA at age 40 to 45
nccn says 45 to 49 but again the key
teaching point is you're getting that
one baseline PSA in men in their 40s and
using that number to determine their
future risk and if that baseline PSA is
less than 1.0 those men are at low risk
for prostate cancer of the next five
years and you can leave them alone for
at least five years if that PSA is safe
for between 1 and 1.5 it's the gray zone
you might want to continue to consider
having them getting tested every couple
of years but if that baseline PSA is
more than 1.5 that is a risk factor in a
red flag for prostate cancer those men
should be followed at least on a one or
two-year basis and I wouldn't do a
biopsy at 1.5 but I would certainly
monitor those patients more closely that
group of men is going to be the
low-hanging fruit for having the most
chance of finding prostate cancer over
the next 10 years now at our institution
we've taken taken a proactive stance
with our primary care network so this
slide illustrates the Duke Cancer
Institute's PSA screening algorithm for
2016 I'm certainly my goal here is not
to go through this and find the tail but
simply to say that our health system has
chosen to be proactive we've rolled out
an educational campaign to our duke
university affiliated physicians on
Primary Care Network and we've chosen to
focus this around baseline PSA and
ethnicity we're trying to identify man
in the 40s who should be followed more
closely and we're trying to identify
high-risk individuals at an age a
younger age where we can make a
difference and so again you'll see more
of this I think as time goes on but this
is our health systems effort to do a
better job of having the urologist work
closely with the primary care physicians
to do a better job in our younger men in
our higher risk men and incorporating
this baseline PSA risk assessment tool
and in fact another thing that we did
this year we took a bold move to buck
the national guidelines about PSA
screening most of the guideline
organizations would say oh don't do any
free prostate cancer screenings that's
not any good certainly the US Preventive
Services Task Force would take us to
task for doing this but we conducted
this in the context of shared decision
no patient got a PSA test willy-nilly
without counseling on the pros and cons
and the other reason we justified this
effort is the fact that fifty percent of
our County Durham County North
Carolina's african-american we have a
crisis in prostate cancer in Eastern
North Carolina with a lower
socioeconomic african-american
population that has one of the highest
rates of prostate cancer in the world so
we felt it was important to do some
focused marketing to try to do a better
job of getting these higher risk
individuals to our prostate cancer
screening and that took place in
September so we have bucked the trend we
do think there's some value in free
prostate cancer screening as long as
it's done in the context of shared
decision-making explaining the pro
and cons and also trying to focus on
high-risk individuals and again why did
you take this bold move on prostate
screening as I said earlier we have a
large african-american population our
university medical practice has
something called Project access we have
a commitment to the entire uninsured
population of Durham County North
Carolina and that's significant
population of african-american man some
who have low socioeconomic status and we
need to do a better job of identifying
prostate cancer in this high-risk
population and potentially trying to
treat it earlier when we can make a
difference so that's why we took the
bold move on prostate screening I want
to switch gears we have a little bit of
time left and just talk a little bit
about new blood markers we focused on
PSA and the PSA prostate-specific
prostate specific antigen test has been
around again since the late 1980s early
1990s it's certainly not going away it's
still forming the basis of the primary
screening test for prostate cancer but
there are a number of new blood markers
and urine markers that are forming
secondary screening tests in other words
the more to fine-tune that PSA test
before you move directly to a biopsy and
you see this headline kallikrein markers
may improve high-grade prostate cancer
detection and reduce unnecessary
biopsies the two blood markers that
we're talking about one is called pH I
and the other one is called the 4k score
these are both blood tests that measure
PSA free PSA and other molecular
components of PSA in the blood and do a
better job than standard PSA in
determining either
man's risk for prostate cancer or is
risk for harboring higher grade prostate
cancer inside his prostate and I won't
spend any more time on these suffice it
to say that these blood tests are also
being incorporated not to replace PSA
but as a complement to PSA in what I
call a secondary screen between the
initial elevated PSA and the prostate
biopsy to try to fine-tune who actually
needs a biopsy and who can be followed a
third test you see on the far right hand
side of the slide is called pca3 that's
a molecular urine test and that's
typically done after a prostate massage
where you get your in and have a patient
giving urine sample and that is also a
useful secondary screen and it's also
the most useful test at a man who's
already had a negative prostate biopsy
but where you have a concern where the
prostate cancer may have been missed on
that first biopsy so you can use a PC a3
pca3 urine test to try to make or make a
better determination of that man needs
another biopsy or can simply be followed
now after a negative biopsy again we
just talked about the PCA three tests
where again you can use this urine test
after a negative prostate biopsy in a
man who where you still are concerned
about prostate cancer another newer test
is called confirm mdx this is a tissue
molecular bio marker done on the
prostate biopsy tissue that was negative
it's based on methylation where if the
benign prostate biopsy tissue is
methylated that indicates that you may
have cancer inside the prostate close by
to where you did the biopsy that you may
just
missed so again confirm mdx is a test
molecular test done on a negative
prostate biopsy to try to determine if
the man may have prostate cancer that
was just missed on that biopsy so the
summary and take home messages from this
talk is that prostate cancer screening
with PSA certainly remains controversial
due to the conflicting results and
methodological issues with the
randomized controlled trials and one of
my take-home messages is that the
American prostate lung colorectal and
ovarian trial the PLC Oh trial that
reported no benefit of PSA testing was
really fatally flawed more than half the
patients in that study in the control
group also had PSA testing so many
experts now think that that study should
not even be considered when taking into
account the benefits of PSA testing
nevertheless it's still listed in the US
Preventive Services Task Force it still
forms a significant reason why the US
Preventive Services Task Force gave the
PSA tested d rating for point number two
the aua guidelines support PSA testing
every two years particularly in men aged
55 and 69 after shared discussion shared
decision now there's also a baseline
risk assessment PSA that we talked about
that's supported by the NCCN and
european guidelines in other words if
you have a patient in your practice is
in the 40s and you choose to do a PSA
test you can use that baseline first PSA
in the 40s as a risk assessment tool
meaning if those men have a PSA
certainly less than 1 or less than one
and a half they're considered lower risk
for future prostate cancer but if that
man at
40 or 45 has a baseline PSA more than
1.5 that's a risk factor for prostate
cancer and those many didn't need to be
followed more closely referred to a
neurologist or be told that they're at
[ __ ] at higher risk for prostate cancer
we talked a little bit about some of the
novel blood and tissue markers that are
entering the field to combat over
detection and overtreatment and we also
talked about active surveillance where
clinicians are not necessarily
aggressively treating many of these
prostate cancers we're still diagnosing
some low-grade cancers but we're much
more comfortable in following some of
these patients without aggressive
treatment now I want to just give some
audience response type questions and
just some key teaching points here's a
49 year old man with poor libido
erectile dysfunction who has a
testosterone level of 122 so he's hypo
game go now he is a low testosterone
level mild bilateral testicular
atropine's prostate is small about 15
grams but he has a PSA level of 2.4 the
next step in this gentleman we'd be to
refer this patient to a urologist and
consideration of a prostate biopsy the
key teaching point is only 49 he has a
PSA that's already 2.4 in the setting of
low testosterone if his testosterone
were normal since PSA is a testosterone
gym and driven on gene his PSA would
even be higher so what we're trying to
teach here is that young man should have
low PSAs and that a young man with a low
testosterone level with hypogonadism
should have a rillo PSA and this 2.4 is
a red flag for him so he should have
consideration of at least referral to
talk to a urologist about the
possibility of a prostate biopsy or at
least close follow-up what is the
optimum PSA screening interval for the
average risk man aged 55 269 who is in
your practice is it one year two years
four years or five years well we
discussed this this was in the aua
guidelines and in this age group 55 269
the most appropriate interval between
PSA test is going to be two years so the
correct answer is B a 59 year old white
male has been on finasteride for bph for
two years and on time you lowson for
three years his current PSA has risen to
3.8 what is the true statement well the
key teaching point the correct answer is
d finasteride lowers the PSA by fifty
percent so this gentleman in reality
even though it says 3.8 he's on
finasteride his PSA is really over seven
and so he's only 59 he has a PSA over
seven corrected on finasteride and
therefore he probably should be seen by
a urologist and urologist would give
careful consideration to possibly doing
a prostate biopsy because this PSA is
significantly higher than it should be
at that age and considering the
treatment of these on so I wanted to be
able to go through those just a couple
of audience response questions and I
want it to warm up the audience for a
number of questions so I think we have
just a few minutes left we're going to
as we've been as I've been speaking a
number of questions have come in from
our listening audience today and I'd
like to go through those questions now
certainly and certainly if you have
other questions you can certainly let us
know the first question comes in from a
listener today
today thank you for that informative
presentation dr. Mao before we get
started on the question-and-answer
session I would like to stir my our
audience how to submit questions you can
send questions by typing them in the Q&A
box which can be found by clicking on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can in
our first question is dr. Mao it reads
how to deal how do I deal with the 40
year old male who desires to be screened
for prostate cancer then get that PSA
result and we would we would then you
know use that PSA number and again if
that PSA was less than 1.5 in that 40
year old man we would probably reassure
him and maybe let him continue to follow
up with his primary care physician but
if the PSA was greater than 1.5 we would
probably talk to him about that he's
higher risk and want to test in a little
bit more often and I was going to now
turn it back over to the moderator to
see if there's any other questions that
came in in the last few minutes thank
you so much actually right here how
important is race and family history in
determining advanced risk for prostate
cancer screen here
so the question is is how important is
race and family history in determining a
man's risk for prostate cancer it's
their very important factors even though
what I talked about earlier was that the
baseline PSA particularly if the
baseline PSA for men in the 40s is above
1.5 that's a strong predictor but so is
ethnicity we know that african-american
patients have a high risk of prostate
cancer we know that men with a family
history of prostate cancer particularly
men who have more than one family member
particularly a father who's diagnosed
with prostate cancer have a higher risk
so those are all important factors thank
you another question is I'm hearing more
about MRI of the prostate and is that
getting more accurate can you tell me
more please I'm hearing
more about MRI of the prostate and that
it is getting more accurate can you tell
me more so great question for many years
[Music]
magnetic resonance imaging was good for
certain conditions but for many years
MRI was felt not to be very accurate for
the prostate or for prostate cancer I
think that what's happened now over the
last several years is advances have
taken place in MRI technology and so
that over the last three or four years
most many major institutions have
something called multi excuse me
multiparametric prostate MRI which is a
specialized technique that allows the
radiologist better imaging of the inside
of the prostate gland this new
multiparametric MRI is done using
specialized equipment at centers of
excellence and generally using a larger
magnet MRI machine typically what they
call a three Tesla MRI magnet and what
we can what we do is we use this MRI and
that gives us better images now
currently in the United States the MRI
is not always covered by insurance plans
in the initial setting meaning if a
patient has an elevated PSA most
insurance plans would cover a prostate
biopsy and a prostate ultrasound but
most insurance plans would not cover a
screening MRI at that
sure on the other hand if you have a
patient who's already been through a
prostate biopsy and already where the
biopsy may not have picked up the cancer
but you have a negative biopsy the
patient has a continued concern about
prostate cancer many times they will
cover the MRI as a secondary screening
test meaning don't they'll do it a
little bit later after the patient is
already had a biopsy but it's it's
definitely improving it's coming along
and more and more Centers of Excellence
around the United States or using
prostate MRI to a greater degree in
determining who gets a biopsy and even
using the MRI to direct the biopsy
another question has come in and I'll
just read it here what is the difference
between these new tests such as pH I the
4k score and pca3 do they replace the
good old PSA tests well the simple
answer is no they do not replace the PSA
test the vast majority of times for an
initial screen for a man in your
practice is going to be the baseline PSA
getting the basic tonal or total plus
free PSA and that still remains the gold
standard the workhorse for prostate
cancer screening however sometimes now
instead of moving directly from an
abnormal PSA directly to a prostate
biopsy sometimes the screening algorithm
is being fine-tuned by ordering a pop pH
I blood test or a 4k score blood test or
pca3 urine test and at least in some
individuals that can help better explain
the PSA test if the PSA is elevated due
to cancer or prostate enlargement or
other causes it can be the secondary
blood or urine tests can fine-tune and
potentially prevent over diagnosis of
small
unimportant cancers and improve
diagnosis of the high-grade important
prostate cancers and I that's it I again
I think that we we don't have any more
time for any other questions again it's
been a fantastic experience being on on
the program today with you i hope that
everyone listening and watching has
gotten something out of this and again i
really want to thank lab groups lab
roots for inviting me to participate in
this important conference have a good
day since there are no more questions
and we run out of time today I like to
once again thank dr. Mao for his
presentation today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
februari 28 2017 you will receive an
email from lab roots alerting you when
this webcast is available for replay
thank you so much have a great day and
good bye from lab rooms